want to see him in his best shape and
there is Magnus
and true to his form he arrives holding
two bottles of water with exactly four
seconds remaining before the start of
the round is Prague carefully adjusts
his pieces the first couple of moves are
going to be particularly important a
warm handshake uh by the ceremonial
guest there and we are about to see the
ceremonial first move which is I think
e2e4 but that does not mean Magnus will
necessarily play E4 the move will be
retracted and then Magnus will make the
official first move of the game
and it appears to in fact be the move E2
E4
yes it was somehow guessable I I think
that also you remember that match
against Vincent kaimer in the decisive
final game that Magnus won he
went for one Euphoria he wanted to play
the Dual Lopez and Prague taking his
time doing the Magnus thing not
answering immediately is he